tre anni fa ho deciso di prendermi la
responsabilità
io ne sono il partito al se cari capire
in che mondo stiamo vivendo qual è il
mondo di oggi
né credo che la cosa corretta stia a
guardare quali sono i modelli del nostro
mondo
perché se guardiamo un antica grecia
vediamo che modelli all'epoca erano i
filosofi pensatori l'antica delle
scienze ha lasciato la democrazia
il pensiero critico e metodo scientifico
così nel rinascimento dove modelli le
persone da abitare erano gli artisti
come leonardo da vinci pittori gli
scultori persone che usavano il cervello
l'intelletto per creare cose belle e
quali sono i nostri modelli sono i
ricchi
oggi il nostro modello di persona a cui
miriamo sono le persone che mettono al
centro della loro vita l'avere mettono
al centro della loro vita i soldi e non
ce ne rendiamo conto ma facciamo così
anche noi non valutiamo più il nostro
lavoro su cosa facciamo
ma su qual è il nostro stipendio la
felicità della nostra famiglia è la
grandezza della nostra casa è la marca
della nostra macchina e lo facciamo
anche perché la stessa società valuta
così le nazioni
valutiamo le nazioni la loro ricchezza
con il prodotto interno lordo
il prodotto interno lordo il pil è la
valorizzazione monetaria di quello che
si crea in quella nazione per il pin il
valore di una scuola non è la capacità
di plasmare e aprire le menti dei
giovani ma il costo dei professori nei
riscaldamenti
così per gli ospedali dove il pil non
valuta la capacità dell'ospedale di far
star bene le persone di farli guarire ma
guarda e valuta il costo degli stipendi
e delle medicine e delle stringhe come
ha detto bob kennedy nel 1968 nel
discorso di chiusura dell'anno
accademico della kansas university il
pil valuta tutto tranne le cose che
rendono la vita degna di essere vissuta
ero così anch'io
mettevo al centro della mia vita e
guadagno cercavo di guadagnare sempre di
più perché volevano a casa più grande
una macchina più bella
fino a quando la vigilia di natale del
2009 è stata diagnosticata una leucemia
acuta b fenotipo uno schifo
sono stato ricoverato tre mesi in camera
sterile fatto tre cicli di chemio una
total body radiation di un trapianto di
midollo osseo
credevo che invece le cose viste sta
andando bene 20 nuovi giorni prima era
nata mia figlia un anno e mezzo prima
mio figlio
stavo guadagnando bene lavoro andava
bene arrivate la malattia con la
malattia questi tre mesi in camera
sterile dove ho avuto la possibilità di
pensare tanto
all'inizio ero arrabbiatissimo mi
chiedevo perché mi sono ammalato perché
proprio a me ho 38 anni o tutta la vita
davanti non è giusto poi fortunatamente
mi son reso conto che comunque anche se
avessi trovato la risposta quella
domanda non starei guarito anche se
avessi capito perché mi ero malato non
sarei guarito
ho capito che la domanda era sbagliata
che non dovevo chiedermi perché stavo
morendo perché mi ero ammalato ma dovevo
chiedermi perché dovevo guarire
dovevo chiedermi perché ero nato allora
ho capito che nasciamo per fare le cose
che ci rendono felici
nasciamo perché la cosa per noi
importante il nostro finestre felice
attraverso fare non invece mettere i
soldi al centro della nostra vita
sono uscito dall'ospedale che ero molto
motivato di cambiare la mia vita
qualche mese sono anche resistito ma poi
il mondo il mondo di oggi è stato più
forte di me mi ha rimesso al centro il
guadagno
un anno dopo mi è tornata la malattia un
altro mese in camera sterile le
intenzioni ancora più forti di cambiare
sono uscite forse non è esistito qualche
mese in più ma poi la vita mia ringhio
tito come prima sono tornato a quello
che ero prima di ammalarmi nel 2016 ma è
tornata per la terza volta la malattia
questa volta non potevo più permettermi
di sottovalutare questo segnale che
continuava arrivarmi dalla vita
e allora deciso di fondare felicia lì
i peli tali sono le persone che mettono
al centro della loro vita la felicità il
fare per essere felici gli estremisti
della felicità
i feliciani sono quelle persone che si
sono coscienti delle cose brutte ma
guardando le cose belle e gestri e vive
la cosa più bella
prendono le leggi e positive per cercare
di risolvere le cose negative
i felicani su quelle persone che sanno
che si vive solo nel qui e ora che
semplicemente vuol dire che le cose si
possono cambiare solo agendo nel
presente il flight tyson quelle persone
che stanno l'importante di stare in
mezzo agli altri perché la felicità non
si somma si moltiplica e soprattutto
l'infelicità si può dividere con gli
altri se il mondo forse pieno di felicia
lì se tutti mettessimo al centro della
nostra vita
il fare per essere felici
sicuramente il mondo sarebbe migliore
questa sera quando tornate a casa
prendete carta e penna e prima di
dormire scrivete tre momenti della
vostra infanzia in cui vi siete sentiti
veramente felici cercate di ricordare
con chi eravate dov'eravate ma
soprattutto cosa stavate facendo quella
del fare che vi rende felici e domani
mettete al centro della vostra vita quel
fare non i soldi
diventiamo un po tutti feliciani e il
mondo sarà un posto migliore soprattutto
per noi per le persone che ci stanno
vicine per i nostri figli e per le
generazioni future
è nostra responsabilità a farlo grazie
[Applauso]